[Applause]
and finally new rule great news about a
new award show
listen to this about a year and a half
ago I was asked to moderate a discussion
at the home of a very prominent
Hollywood producer and the attendees
that night was a who's who of a-listers
and stars if a bomb went off in that
room there'd be nothing on TV next year
but well let's just say it would be a
great year for Kevin Sorbo
[Laughter]
I can't say exactly who was there but if
there really is a Jewish space laser
these guys have the codes
anyway the subject we all wanted to talk
about that night was cancel culture it's
funny if this was 10 years ago this
group would have been talking about
censorship from the right back then it
was the Jerry falwells and Pat
Robertsons the bill Bennetts and Rush
Limbaugh's who kept us up at night I
mean besides the cocaine
book banners and boycotters than were
Republicans like the ones that got me
fired after 9 11. but that's in the past
now and by the past I mean Florida
all right
and of course not just Florida today's
Republicans have shown that when it
comes to canceling they're still more
than capable they canceled Colin
Kaepernick for taking a knee Liz Cheney
for defying Trump Kathy Griffin for
performance art
just last week the redneck royalty of
the music world through a hissy fit
because they think Anheuser-Busch is
turning their beer gay
Anheuser-Busch
but there's no getting around the fact
that what was on the mind of the
Liberals that night in Brentwood or
wherever we may have been
was that the most powerful witch Hunters
now were coming from Twitter the ivy
league and the progressive left JK
Rowling used to be a villain to the
right because she wrote books about
witchcraft
now she's a villain to the left because
she has the crazy belief that there's
more to being a woman than pronouns and
lipstick
[Applause]
that was the point of the evening how do
we take a stand against cancel culture
and I suggested since we were mostly all
in Show Business that we start an award
show to honor the brave people who have
fought back
well
I got to tell you the idea was met with
great enthusiasm by everyone and in
short order different people were
suggesting the ways that their varied
talents could be put to use and then of
course being Hollywood nothing happened
but it's still a good idea so I'm gonna
do it right here right right now
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen you know the Emmys
you know the Grammys you know the Tonys
now say hello to the cojones
tonight from Hollywood the first annual
cojones Awards
honoring outstanding achievement in
growing a pair
and now here's your host
Bill Maher
thank you
thank you and welcome to the cajones I'm
your Master of Ceremonies and if you're
triggered by the word Master you're in
the wrong room
foreign
these solid brass balls
to the individuals and organizations who
others have tried to silence and who
answered that's not a rule you
our first award goes to the president of
my alma mater Cornell University Martha
Pollock this month students there
demanded trigger warnings before all the
lectures in case any of the adult
subjects you specifically went to
college to learn about came up
and Martha said yeah
we're not doing that she didn't cave in
or hire a new Dean of sensitivity she
just said no colleges were introducing
you to new ideas not for kissing your
ass and making you feel wonderful and
always right
you're thinking of brunch with your
parents
I'm just amazed at how this generation
can simultaneously be too sensitive for
anything distasteful and somehow also so
into eating ass
foreign
ell I present you with these balls I
sure could have used them when I was
there
our next award goes to the place where
many Cornell grads will be working next
year Trader Joe's
[Laughter]
Trader Joe's who for years have been
selling a line of ethnically themed
products Trading
on the name Joe for example they have
Trader Jose's beer
so of course one teenager on Twitter
heard the word Jose and said it was
racist and then there was a petition and
then Trader Joe's management did the
right thing they burnt down all their
stores and killed themselves
[Applause]
no they didn't they said off you
oversensitive little shits
get a life and a sense of humor and
release this statement we disagree that
any of these labels are racist and we do
not make decisions based on petitions
you see how easy it is
so to the home of the 19 Cent banana
here have some nuts
this next Cooney goes to a man who's
dear to my heart for standing up for
stand up when dozens of Netflix
employees walked out over Dave
Chappelle's Reckless decision to perform
comedy on his comedy special
CEO Ted sarandos could have pulled the
special and replaced it with more
episodes of who wants to watch Koreans
get killed
but instead he reminded his Netflix
employees that comedy exists to push
boundaries and told them if you'd find
it hard to support our content breath
Netflix may not be the best place for
you
so for making the phrase don't let the
door hit you in the ass never sound
better
this is for you Ted
and you know
you know when movie lovers get together
these days one phrase that comes up a
lot and always makes me sad is yeah you
couldn't make that one today
top of that list is the great Tropic
Thunder
which these scolds have been after for
years but in February Ben Stiller
tweeted I make no apologies for Tropic
Thunder it's always been a controversial
movie since when we opened proud of it
and the work everyone did on it see
people it's not that hard
he said it and he's still got a
commercial
and the
lesson is if you stand up to the Mob for
just a day or two they're shallow
impatient immature smartphone-driven
gerbil Minds will forget about it and go
on to the next nothing burger and you
you still will have your cojones